so during covid yeah
um the first person that interviewed a
doctor that got 20 million views that
got everybody thinking was Joe Rogan Joe
Rogan interviewed this one doctor I
don't know who it was I don't remember
the guys no no no no no this is Phase
One no this is March of 2020. if you can
pull it up you'll see who he was he
interviewed this guy and he got you know
Joe was saying so listen I'm being told
if I go into Asana if I sit in the you
know steam room and I sweat it out and
it says nope this is not that this is
this and it wasn't a person that would
have said it otherwise so people
believed it and said okay maybe this is
something we have to pay close attention
to anyways during covid I believe Joe
played a very important role very super
important super necessary voice I was
telling them where to get outside I
don't know if you realize this you may
be one of the most necessary voices in
America on what you've been able to do
so now
Alex Jones will say to Joe and I've
heard Alex say you know I know Joe
believes this stuff but Joe knows how to
maneuver around it yeah and he's just
like learning how to maneuver him but I
know he believes me but he acts like he
does it with him but I don't know maybe
so you know and Alex is saying this
about Joe so then you hear uh what's his
name you hear
um
Dave Chappelle does a comedy special
yeah and he says hey ladies I just want
to tell you you know I think one of the
most miraculous things you can do is
have a baby yeah it's you know you
should have freedom of choice yeah I'm
for you you should have all the ladies
yeah all the ladies said you should have
a feeling of choice but there's about if
you choose to keep the baby I can also
choose not to pay child support yeah
yeah then all of a sudden people wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait no no
no that's not no no it's not cool
because this isn't so then but some
people say well listen
he makes a very good point yeah if it's
your choice it should be my choice
whether I should pay or not but whether
he's right or not it's irrelevant it
started the conversation then the one
bit he did about so I see this card
there's the LGBT everybody that's in
there's a queer there's this there's the
trans there's this there's that right
and he calls out the transgender
community and they're about to cancel
this guy right okay
neither Joe nor Chappelle got canceled
correct that's good for society oh great
hear me out agree that's good for
society that neither Jewish
Society needs these two guys oh great
because they get to talk about stuff
that gets everyone to be on the edge now
Joe almost got canceled almost that came
from very much the hardcore the elbow he
almost got canceled because of the
n-word or because of all these other
videos that resurfaced and he came out
and did this video and he said here's
what am I watch it etc etc and then
Chappelle took his angle as well would
they try to cancel him as well
but all I'm saying is from how we need
certain people to be out there pushing
the envelope in questioning the status
quo so you're looking back for yourself
right now there may be a lot of people
now you can say like I'm not solving to
be a YouTuber yeah I'm not solving to be
on Tick Tock I'm not solving to be on
Instagram but
the messaging is not going to be as
visible I agree as as great as you know
uh Rumble stock is up and 12 all this
other stuff I totally get it I hope they
blow up I think it's great for Facebook
to have a competitor but it's not that
say first of all I want to give your
thoughts on that but say you do get
a second try at this okay so you do get
a second Friday
what adjustment would you make and
that's a good question and I understand
your point absolutely and I agree with
you the world would be a better place
with me on these mainstream platforms
what's interesting is I think they
killed me in my infancy even though I
became the most Googled man on the
planet it was very very meteoric
happened very quickly I had already had
conversations with my team internally
understanding that now that I'm the most
famous man on the planet I have to
create my messaging not say anything
different or say it in a different way
we were already doing that for a month
prior to the band we had already changed
a lot of the messaging changed our Stan
not stance we said the same things but
changed the way we'd say certain things
remove certain subjects altogether and
we were already creating our messaging
however they looked at me and I think
that the social media company saw me as
uh perhaps a 19 year old Warrior who's
soon going to become a warrior king and
thought we'd either kill him now or he's
going to become too big to kill and and
they decided to kill me now I've only
been the most I've only been super viral
for six months if they would have given
me a year the messaging would have
absolutely been created to a point that
I don't think they would have deleted me
at all my one of my last posts on
Instagram
was I wrote this as post I said I
understand that certain people have
false narratives about me and I'm
looking to correct them so on Instagram
I put up a post saying that for every
like this picture gets I'm going to
donate two dollars one dollar to female
charity to protect them against domestic
violence and one dollar to men's mental
health Charities two dollars per like to
show that all my haters who only talk
negative I actually do something to fix
the problem I take the negativity and I
turn it into light as God would want me
to do I'm gonna donate money it was a
seven day countdown Instagram deleted me
on the sixth day when I have at the time
of deletion I had 555 000 likes it's 1.2
million dollars I was prepared to donate
to Charities nobody wants to talk about
that nobody wants to mention it because
I'm evil right at the time of my
deletion when I got deleted the only
appeal I sent to Instagram the only
message I sent was can you confirm the
number of likes on that picture so I can
finish my donation
they ignored me completely you're not
really didn't even want to reply to me
so I was already understanding that the
way you can say certain things when you
have 300 views on a video where most of
these views got 300 views has to be
created and changed not because I'm
saying anything incorrect but as a
professional you have to understand that
things change and also no matter what
you say a very small contingent of the
world will misunderstand it if not 0.1
percent of people misunderstand you
that's not a problem when you have three
interviews a video that is a problem
when you get three million views of
video so me and my team had already
accepted this already decided upon it
and had already implemented it but the
momentum was so strong and the rise was
so meteoric that the social media
companies even a month after
implementation decided I'm sure they sat
around and said we kill him now or he's
going to become too famous to kill and
they thought we have to try and kill him
now now they have failed
Rumble in and of itself has proved
they've failed I get more views on my
Rumble view videos that I got on my
YouTubes when I did a YouTube live
I had around 12 000 views on my first
ever Rumble live I had 127 000. on my
second I had 75 000. so they've martyred
me and made me more famous than ever but
the message has already been created and
changed I understand very very well
because that's a professional you have
to take accountability for everything I
understand I have a 15 year old kid
without my life experience without my
credentials listens to me not in full
but in segments small parts and then
takes on board it may negatively affect
some of his outlooks I understand that
my counter argument is this find
anything on the entire internet where if
it's not chopped in a negative way and
fed the 15 year old kids where it cannot
be a detriment that's the entire
internet that's anybody we've already
talked about modern culture having sex
with the devil on TV transgenders
whatever they're trying to do make kids
chop their dicks off whatever we've
talked of all this so that's the entire
internet that's not an argument against
me that's an argument against the
internet as a whole but I was
responsible enough as an adult to say
okay I'm still going to take that in
mind and I'm still going to be
responsible for that myself and change
my messaging which I intended on doing
but they already decided to Nuke me
absolutely and completely and that's
where
part of me
I don't want to be too defiant I'm
certainly not looking to go to war with
anybody but part of me is kind of like I
would have never ever been controlled
opposition because I can't be bought and
sold but I would have had very very
detailed conversations with social media
execs and say what are you truly
uncomfortable with the way you say this
okay well here's what I'm trying to say
yes okay so what if I said it this way
okay cool let's work together but they
didn't want to be reasonable logical
actors they wanted to just try and
annihilate me hoping I would disappear
and they're realizing in real time that
they that I didn't disappear so now I'm
sitting here ideologically thinking
do I give a [ __ ] what they think anymore
I I only care about making sure my
message is a positive for the world do I
really give a [ __ ] what YouTube want now
so if they do let me back yeah sure I
understand something has to be created
Etc et cetera but my my messaging will
remain true the things I say I do mean
they are genuinely a positive and this
could have been a positive experience
for social media for me how much money
did I bring to social media companies I
almost viewed man on the planet not a
single monetized video
they wouldn't monetize me billions of
unmonetized views how much money were
they making yeah like it could have been
great for everybody if you enjoyed this
video and you want to watch the entire
podcast click over here and if you want
to be connected with experts influencers
such as Kiyosaki Tate Connolly
parliamentary myself and others download
the app connect where you get a chance
to connect with these folks by the
minute you get to buy the minute or have
face times with them 15 minutes ask them
any questions you may want to have
download the app minute and start
connecting with influencers and experts
today
foreign
[Music]